marry not in good shape I look like [ __ ]
I blame myself look at me look at my
hefty limp here giving krebons or to get
rid of on super-slow I still have them
oh my god I'm so sorry
was it been like two weeks since we last
recorded it's been a really long time
because I went do I think that I went on
vacation I went to Florida I feel like I
was gone before that too we had to
record a couple in a row I was gone I
was back on the East Coast for work
but now we're together again - do you
know just deal with Leon I'm seriously
injured I need I need go through their
meds I think I have no meds I have
nothing and I'm in the danger zone
I'm going outdoors so last episode you
went through the door behind you you got
the diamond key and yeah Bishop plug
from that room I remember you need
Bishop oh god employment there's no
zombies in here right because I'm really
sick
observe how slow I am leave me alone a
hefty limp he's got he's everything
you'd be I it - below you I really need
these don't use that and then I have a
yeah I got this hot diamond key that I'd
like to use and they is it just like a
key it's like a regular story
yeah it's essentially like Joe has the
water sorry claire has a lockpick so you
don't need to have the key no no the
keys for keys for pretty cool upgrade
actually which we'll get to
I'm sure you'll like it you'll approve
oh I feel so much fine go through this
door actually really should be much fast
I am just to do some hard dodging
upstairs and down here actually
Debbie do you have more find out here Oh
God I hear them no what am i doing tell
me what to do oh god toward the camera
let's look at the map your map okay so
I'm in the lead dudes place that it's a
heart so I don't want that so I want to
go furred come out of this so I want to
go straight this room yeah there's gonna
be like a bunch of zombies though you
didn't you feel like cat mouse and
around the table of pasta
all right and then I'm right after that
when I get through the door yeah okay
yikes oh God go go you dum-dum where are
they
I can't count Mouse if I don't know
where they mouse the mouse [ __ ] I can't
can mouse um yeah get out get out go
past that there he's stuck thank God but
don't eat me go around him
yeah but just no reset no I meant like
I'm sorry I meant like reset they need
you to clear oh don't worry don't worry
don't worry I am injured though I did
get into it's fine I thought that guy
was dead I know it's dammit yep
oh my own caution already come on come
on [ __ ] okay so come this way and then
towards me towards towards real people
there better not be anything in here I
am you don't have a gun equipped also oh
god at this isuh
okay get Dorothy in the hallway yikes
that was a bad start
I'm not doing so hot I just want to live
like straight-up live
I think he's go directly down this
hallway gonna Happ is to be believed
good look now knowing you like it when I
look at my mouth yeah okay try it out
oh that's a pink door and I got a pink
key what was that
here we go I'm actually before tway home
bring a map up really quick nevermind
what I was thinking I was gonna make
sure there wasn't anything else in this
wing you could I was that keep it well I
got a second get here there's a pink
door over there
yeah that's I'm saying I was making sure
there's nothing close by just finally
using its on the other side they do that
on purpose so you can't just discard the
key here I'm trying to think of what
you're missing in this hallway I mean
you can check out the rest of Holly
before you go through that door Oh
stealing I really don't get any more red
kakuka burn it with the green [ __ ] yeah
yeah did it yeah great
everyone wins this is a good day for
everyone all right cool
nice nice all right
everything's coming up millhouse we're
doing okay coming up millhouse come on
where's that from get on the trolley
what other thing do you know of in the
whole world has the name Milhouse I
don't know anything with a name Milhouse
really really I'm making my older sister
I'm making myself seem young I know that
but you don't everyone young and old
knows The Simpsons should I take this
Gordon yeah
let me tell you a tale my silly friend
Milhouse has really high high water
pants and when his house gets flooded
did you suck at picking up first-aid
sprays yes when his house gets flooded
[ __ ] spray his shoes are wet but his
cuffs are bone dry and he says
everything's coming up millhouse cuz it
is that's me just something on that
shelf
no wonder if you want to take this or
not uh-oh everyone's a ripple I was
thinking that was the film yeah did you
know we need to do that no you might as
well think she'd be good well good cuz
my inventory is super full come on
boss shotgun I don't have it all you
didn't take a shotgun with you Jimmy no
I thought you had it
you have the shotgun no I don't you have
two shells oh that's fine that's fine
well good news you have first aid spray
you can you oh my god I use first aid
spray went the wrong way through a
one-way mirror I don't think that's how
one way use that yet I don't think you
go through one-way mirrors either away
clear map up don't act like you know
now I [ __ ] dying go into that other
room now why he jumped from take a right
oh go into the room they jump from when
you just come in no yeah like the room
next door do I need to use my caution
spray now right now I mean be ready to
use it but don't use it okay so in here
my inventories fold up Tara oh my god
[ __ ] shotgun I thought you'd still be
another one cuz I had to turn around yes
no no you'll be fine turning around
you're saying what should your shotgun
with you [ __ ] I thought you had it I
it's okay
alright I'm turning around really slowly
I'm gonna leave here we go
alright so I need to go to a save box is
what you're telling me that's how I feel
sure the other option is I go to okay
cuz I haven't done that yet alright
that's not good you try it oh I don't
think I'm gonna be able to get in here I
think you're gonna tell me that aren't
you yeah
Club green doors or clubs um do you be
fine just go do the do the heart key on
the other side of it
wait no I don't want to go through here
this is the police part yeah but all
those [ __ ] they're gonna have to
they're gonna eat me gonna have to oh
you get much better like Upstairs
Downstairs why shoot them because
they're all killing me every time I go
back and forth no um
Markham I will ma'am this is way more
stressful in the first one like I'm
feeling it right but it's good what do
you mean it's a good shot through there
don't get upset with me I'm sorry I was
like thinking I was like what policemen
officers you talking about
now you're in the main lobby you're fine
hey Cher all right so healed that liquor
right didn't you kill the first liquor
in this oh yeah Jesus I need to like go
back and watch the show it's been a
while I thought we decided to just keep
dodging also he's not in here yeah but
you're gonna have to go through there oh
I see you don't have me you could go
upstairs I could point put the plug away
yeah and put it with the other plugs and
I got this hot cord put the and I got in
green herb way all right okay you're
growing boy do you want the key bring
the she I even know if you need the
shotgun now I you know what I just feel
better with it but the cord away after
the incident there's a box after one all
I'm a little hazy on the items and -
yeah you should be good
you're just easy in general like I'm
always easy that reaction to just be
like just bust out your shotgun try that
cabinet all right good call what stop
getting upset because it makes me upset
so the other [ __ ] the other pink one is
through a bunch of crap I gotta go all
the way around the entire outskirt it's
not it's not that bad it's like that
hallway where the harmless hands come
through the boarded up windows all right
all right so I'm just going yeah okay
here we go what else are you missing in
this room what do you mean says you
didn't pick something up Oh mmm I could
touch stuff let me touch stuff
that's top run these around like the
reception desk
okay I really look like [ __ ]
how about this guy
this
what about the centerpiece then you try
that doesn't seem like it reacts to my
clicking I don't know to be determined
later the liquor no no no I hope he's
dead
wasn't he dad didn't we did him good
fine flank flank there we need more
shotgun shells it'd be more comfortable
killing them all right is there anything
in here it's just the hands was just
keep going around
that's all the way around on the outside
but then here trailer park rally outside
all right so I go through the store and
I take a right what did you pick up here
with them
Oh am I missing stuff
yeah I'm missing see crows left and
right man no please don't
all right take a right yeah so this is
the bottom of the staircase that film
rooms over an area it should be the last
beam via monkey I discarded the key what
why you're getting you're getting more
harder to scare no you want to get
something in there so grenade no I mean
like yeah you need to I would say whoa I
use my shotgun here's what I propose
you have a typewriter you only save I
would say I'm right at the bottom of the
stairs you have a DC of 5 ink ribbons 4
or 5 which is more than enough and then
ya go in and with a shotgun and just one
shell ideally get like three head shots
okay like a line and then runs toward
the camera turn around and use your
pistol on the other guy
oh right I'm a big dum-dum
oh this is a hard one are you stressed
out I'm stressed out no move oh right
yeah bring just bring the other shotgun
shells in case I could combine them yeah
just once you leave the item box
oh come on get around there you big
dum-dum all right so I'm doing it yeah I
don't want to lose 20 minutes progress
either but I do worry that later on I'm
gonna want these ribbons you will but
you'll find pretty fine for your first
time you haven't saved that much for
where you are you're trying to guide you
as little as possible but if it like
becomes if it becomes like game
breakingly desperate yeah like when it's
like to the point where I'm gonna have
to redo the game yeah that happens in
this series but doesn't really like it
in this game you can get to a point
where like you just can't function
pretty much especially there's anything
got check bosses and whatnot what's a
gut-check boss like the real tests of
whether you've been playing correctly
the whole time all right so I need to
equip my shotgun and I need to don't
worry about that you just say it so
don't worry about your health yet you
remember how I get like like aim upward
a little bit did you reload I didn't see
yes so I try to get the headshot I don't
know how to up work aim upwards a little
bit they might not be bunched up no I'm
sorry now a little bit just a mob words
then you get the headshots they might
not be bunched up enough for you to do
it but you can try oh I'm gonna try try
for the headshots if not lower it
quickly and just blast them to give
yourself some spots boss and then run
toward the camera and eat this face
oh god just blast them
oh [ __ ] okay
nice okay I would I would go on I didn't
think this through
that second shot was actually really
good you just barely caught that guy to
your right oh yeah uh equip and just
shoot him he's gonna hit me he's gonna
get me
yeah you'll go that you should go down
to danger I'm worried you're on the
bottom end of caution [ __ ] it you just
save just yeah
pistol great so should I try to dodge
him I could try to dodge him but you
could try okay just shoot him a few
times a lot get up
no shoot him on the ground keep your
[ __ ] waste them nice keep shooting
nice I am in danger right yeah that's
probably the best outcome we can hold
right there know what's alive don't
don't walk he doesn't have blood I don't
think she put a round in his stomach no
something else is there twitching their
heads are blowing off their fun oh no
he's dead okay cool
no hmm he might not be dead just step on
his face anyway actually don't do that
dead yeah hey sweet alright what am i
doing I got a map go behind those on no
cuz that's where all the Psalms are so
are they in cages no wait I know okay so
check this uh it was desk to here right
I heard I think those boxes what am I
saying
the desk should be good should should
have something okay nevermind just go
behind the morgue things wherever that
says evidence room sorry oh no oh no
it's fine you're fine I'm not fine back
up and learn towards you just shoot him
you just you're giving him the walk
toward you see okay Oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
use a shotgun shell on them or night
come toward the camera this way and then
use your your handgun this way no no no
not toward them go left
alright never mind pull your shotgun out
I feel like you were confusing me
no I meant come toward the camera like
run away from him okay wait he's coming
I'm gonna be on caution don't worry
I would actually since you just say
recommend reloading that last thing
really it went that badly it could have
gone so much better if you got like you
stuck with a shotgun your health would
be more important than those I'm on fine
okay yeah it wasn't bad actually you're
good I'm fine am i hitting the wrong
button just tell me there's something
back here what this is where you get the
this should be check check the and like
I have no reaction to anything there you
go if you want you can leave here and go
develop it just to get rid of it oh
right cuz I have the film room yeah do
that before you go through this other
door oh the stores unlocks but you don't
you don't want to go through there yet
okay all right just get rid of the films
what I'm saying I understand you don't
the film's unnecessary but it's it adds
some flavor
all right so here oh no the safe room Oh
Reina to the back of the safe room
that's right the dark room the darker
okay some flava flav here we go
it's a Jonathan from strange things he's
developing those photos that chick when
the other girl walks in
I could develop film you're phony I had
film we're gonna need guns lots of guns
I did it ooh
human Kouji human body experiment looks
like a little fetus giant arm oh yeah I
thought that was the g-virus I thought
it was a face with three legs me too
all right cool so there's some flavor
got someplace nice so now I could should
I go through that door now yeah do I
need anything should I quit my shotgun
don't lie to me
oh hang on I'll be fine don't you know
you'll be fine
what I'm secretly trying to get you
killed so you can redo the evidence yeah
that would be recrawl I don't think it
went that badly like a map check him out
really quick okay there still is
something in here um yeah I'll check the
desk again maybe you should weren't
aligned with it perfectly or something
oh this check the drawers at this desk
cuz you were like there's stuff in here
misremembering where it is no don't go
through that door though check check
that that odx yeah just check them for
evidence drawers I guess okay cuz like
typically he has commentary on stuff
like this like he'd be like books yeah
just check their drawers like he's got
nothing to draw like on the other side
on the other side of this room like over
here yeah
he just looks done his [ __ ] doing this
he does it's because he is dumb because
he's not there you go
okay sweet should be it I was thinking I
couldn't run for his hand got her
shotgun shells these in shape with
shotgun shells okay
the room should be clear all right yeah
go through here no no no there's a
cutscene
it's the party room this were made it
looks like you parties that's that's an
herb can I have it
what's your inventory looking like go
for it you're also really close to the
entrance hall was that mean this is the
you're right next to the entrance hall
now so you have some easy access to say
oh that's my friend nothing suspicious
just a carton full of what looks like
blood
hey you know get up skipper should I
kill him I should kill him yeah but turn
around and run first is some space
between you and this Jamo oh crap it
didn't work out I don't know if this is
warranted for one guy
it's he likes powerful well run again
do you like to shot salmon run why is
the why is it so scary
Lucas seen a Monty Python the Holy Grail
and Lancelot John Cleese sprinting it's
like I cut back he's not even moving I
don't understand it's just one guy I
don't know it's just like it's that's
the first time you've seen someone
change yeah it showed it like in real
time I guess
check him out it's just like I've seen
some [ __ ] recently she got a key on that
desk you know I mean like I've seen some
stuff so it's not so that's a spade
upside down its heart should be someone
else in this room not this room but like
overall yeah the desks well there is but
how about over here a memo to Leon
Kennedy congratulations on your
assignment in the Raccoon City Police
Department we all look forward to having
you as a part of our team and promise to
take you take good care of you welcome
aboard you're gonna say it
welcome aboard lianna's Kennedy Leona's
Kennedy anything else we can look at the
map yep uh yeah I think it's a desk
those lockers might be see you're on the
other side of that
okay that's probably it I mean a desk
but I don't know that it matters right
now because come back oh that white
paper looks promising
No okay I hate doing this got the
evidence shelf behind you Evan shelves
he wasn't his office he checked both
lockers yeah let's try the evidence
like I didn't look here on this
bookshelf I don't think this is like his
kid or something on the desk
okay uh I don't know I thought I checked
everything I feel like that was
everything oh I didn't check the other
shelves right the ones on the left
I did try that the family cabinet I did
know the finally comes you're right this
thing that small one to the right my
writer his room okay like you're upset
no it's on the docket for today
Michael Festival who's Michael festival
do you mean this cuz there's a table in
the way did you mean this yes all right
you guys just leave I'm not gonna be
read should I go through this door yes
you have the Harkey now you can go
through read doors
god I hope there's no zombies on the
other end
how - Lobby okay good because I'm having
a [ __ ] game good so you want to go to
the East Wing
Laura floridi swing into that Red Room
mm-hmm all the red door you're gonna
have to go through those zombies again
but you'll be fine you'll be fine hey I
will not be fine if evidence has shown
that my at the record show I don't write
that down
don't let the red you stop typing that
stop typing that the classic
stenographer conundrum
I've been trying court before I know
when did you go to jail
oh I guess I didn't go jelly
take a right yeah I want to know why you
went to jail probably for something
really dumb like throwing a full awful
lot of truck or something [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry all right all
right
okay yeah whatever for throwing a full
athletic truck did you just say yeah
that wasn't my guess you're going toward
the camera wait oh really really just
kidding um way what's your inventory
looking like it's pretty good I could
combine two greens don't do that yeah
just take them both and then depending
on what you get after this because you
could come across a red one and be more
useful
I'm in a lot of trouble no you're good
yeah decent ammunition decent green
herbs stop it
so what did you almost go to jail for
throwing a falafel on a truck
no sorry throwing a burrito at a falafel
truck started a feud between the falafel
and the burrito guys a war where am i
I've ever been a holy window room I've
been here before yeah you have the
stairs the end you can't go through that
Club door yet this is just the better
this is a good decent shortcut I guess
to have so you don't have to go all the
way through the West Wing if I go
upstairs okay so where should I go
oh I think you wanna be the east drop
the stairs and then pull the map I'm
trying to think even the east or west
this will be faster in my wife but it
might be a lot more it's not a few more
zombies I really like oh wait wait go to
that oh this
oh I have cord uh-huh what's in your
safe room across that down below you may
be downstairs do you wanna check
downstairs
no actually go upstairs I don't have an
upstairs oh [ __ ] sorry downstairs you're
right no you don't have a basement yet
there's this door that's a club door I
think okay I gotta go back where I came
from
oh man there's all those freaking police
and every time oh you don't think every
time I go downstairs they try downstairs
and before you use the backup here as a
last resort
that was my fault should sleep in the
core afraid you'd come across that at
this point it's okay that's okay I don't
know you need the cord to go down here
knows it I hear it I hear it do the cord
so turn around yeah walk in a little bit
in this your gods limping so that's the
dog noise a man before legs [ __ ] I gotta
go back to the precinct again these guys
suck like they've taken a chunk out of
me every time I go through I feel like I
should just shoot them mmm
like I hate these guys they keep doing
have to go
where are they no yes oh okay wait here
as long as possible
like over near the door bait this dude
get out yeah
now go this way that you might have one
dude in your face though you probably
will actually he's gonna be right around
this corner oh you're good oh the door
like sprint nice yes
that's my first solid Juke of the entire
episode honestly of the episode yeah
yeah I've had no good Jukes right oh
wait cuz like isn't that my god that's
the main area this is right
or if you have to dodge a liquor you
rather just they both suck but I'm been
consistently both the ladder and then to
the left to the left save room I've been
fairly consistent with the lid I would
actually go up a ladder I know there's
gonna be some bees or you didn't kill
those guys but I need to get the cord
first right that's I'm saying I'm trying
to figure out what the best closest a
room would be I'm also I probably don't
need to take all these herbs right I can
probably put an herb away - okay you
definitely want to show them I have it
yeah just thinking out loud so you think
I should go upstairs and dodge that's
what you think I don't know no not
anymore you're good this way I'm just
saying I was I was thinking you were
gonna say very I don't know what I was
thinking you're good yeah I don't think
you know what you're doing yeah I'm
taking a left and I'm going back through
the precincts and I'm gonna take out
those dogs yeah okay
well use the car can I dodge the dogs or
do I have to kill them if you have
enough space down the hallway you could
probably a few pistol rounds off for you
- shotgun Hey these this police precinct
really sucks like I actually don't know
how to dodge them like I don't I feel
like it's impossible go behind him go to
reset if you can nice okay that works
that was just luck that was dumbass luck
it was okay that was luck like in
[ __ ] I did not earn that I panicked
and went forward nothing happened
oh right I'm just kidding
I thought you were look at me okay cool
okay I don't know what I don't know the
significance of what I've just done
where's the button the cord will short
out soon wait press that big red button
oh this this [ __ ] with you damn you
sconce tears I didn't know if we needed
the cord she's got a surge in fun it'll
help I use a shotgun against the dogs
you've got enough space down the hallway
too
get a few pistol rounds off before he
starts like sprinting a don't hit down
where is he
just shoot no now shoot keep shooting
just get ready to play your stock enough
to come at you fast whoa cool
yeah you're good they're a little more
reactive to handgun around - just shoot
when I hear something grow it's a pretty
accurate system so far come on y'all
[ __ ] I hear your little pitter-patter
just shoot I could just shoot mmm
you can I don't know try it yeah these
might be stuck on it's like the corner I
hear it kill me
all right you understand the layout of
this room oh that's that's unfortunate
[ __ ] all right I think he's toward the
light such a Leon's right okay so take
her think so look to the right or here's
what you could do oh yeah just walk I
have a 50/50 chance that what you're
saying is right walk into that hallway
no and then back up there try to back up
you're not gonna back up fast obviously
but yeah
or just [ __ ] go for it yeah there you
go nice do it should have
I tried always to keep shooting keep
shooting keep shooting
keep shooting [ __ ] you might have reload
don't eat down Addai use healthy healthy
healthy tough use how yours help combine
those and use them right now don't aim
down just keep shooting yeah we can
speed through now we know we're doing
cuz I aim down I really thought I had it
if he didn't run behind me I think I
could have done it
shy but I should have told you play your
shotgun I was pretty confident the
handgun though well what did we learn
well now you can mitigate a lot of
damage done to you I think in the long
run this will be better you can you know
you understand how far back I have to go
it's really not as far as you think
because we're just taking it all so
you're gonna go in this next room the
shotgun do it better this time yeah
you're good I have to get the film and
do ever you don't need to do the film at
all I just told you get it
No
I see for the flavor yeah you really
need the chords I already went down what
do you mean I don't need the court is
that for flavor - no I wasn't for flavor
it's just like you won't need it yet so
okay so get it right now you know to
come back to another saying all right
hon you're gonna get the heart key that
was actually a little heartbreaking
I like almost had it dude like I almost
had it
all right so speed through the [ __ ] no
that's how you die just don't I don't
even know if I would recommend go for
headshots you can just do it you're fine
he's blasting water okay just wait wait
until I tell you to do it okay just wait
for these now it's all right you don't
need to use that first-aid yet though no
satisfied with me it's okay
put your hand get over this I can't oh
they need to go back there for the film
no [ __ ] it don't even go back there
don't worry about that last guy just
remember he's there if we ever go
through here again you're not going to
you okay shotgun shells party room and
that's in here all right so I'm going
that guy dead let's hope uh yeah through
there
- dude kill the weight already dude kill
the party - oh right yeah breaky yeah
you're really not you didn't lose that
much time and besides more entertaining
when you die
well I don't get that herb I don't feel
so great about what's gone down here
today that's all right that's part of
resin evil you're getting the real
experience Am I
yeah am i yeah shoot this [ __ ]
so what are how they're gonna make that
look in the remaster back up
[ __ ] Chet Chet I [ __ ] up actually I
think that happened last time cuz he hug
in your face yep kit you could I guess
the shock I want to help you shoot him
he takes Barry get to this doorway
I'm I'm in trouble
yeah it's a sprain I don't feel like I'm
doing you're really not in that bad
shape it's the first time playing again
it's the first time you think tank
controls all right sweetheart key across
the lobby you're gonna go through that
precinct but oh here's I'm recommending
when you come through the door turn Leon
to his right and run behind that first
guy unless you want to try to shoot the
gap no I'll try don't do anything at
this point was there anything else in
here that I let me get the handgun ammo
I'm trying to remember it's probably
going back to haunt me after we end the
episode I'm gonna remember what you
missed but at least it's right off the
main hall okay so there's I'm pretty
sure I remember so I'm going through
here yes yeah to do the East Wing door
pinkie swing like it's a mansion but
East corridor
it's [ __ ] dogs I'm really upset about
what kill the first one to piss on this
place shotgun out okay no actually not
even that you could if you have him in
front of you finally pistol he's gonna
shoot I'm shooting hidden behind the
corner and then when I got in front of
the corner I got ramshackled alright so
here wait don't pull your mama they
think it's yeah yeah I gotta go through
that hallway yeah right
like I said when he comes to the door
turn him I got a year I have to turn him
yeah
go behind the guy in your left your left
go behind him there you go nice perfect
okay
we less anxiety surrounding it that's
great that's a great little thing to
know I feel really good about that me
too
okay
I don't have room for everything they
both I'll be full you're about to get
rid of the cord and that's it
no you should be why don't ya leave that
here when I get it on the way back to
come back yeah you'll be fine I'll come
back you don't know do you come back
through here yeah yeah ask what the
chord with there's a lot of doors the
basement to check cool that went well
all right so now I'm gonna kill some
[ __ ] dogs you ready go back behind
there again
Brian where the staircase is really I
know it was a club we were sorry
did you check that shelf is anything on
the shelf nice nice nice okay
I feel Joe feel I feel better about this
was that really all we did yes it's just
you're less there's less trepidation
when you do it your second time jeez
it's why the game gets faster every time
you play it all right here we go [ __ ]
this mutt up show yourself
tell you what I'm not gonna do I'm not
gonna point down come on I like this
system the old growl shoot so I do with
dogs into their life I'm kidding I like
dogs a lot all right two down so the
same issue I'm on the same issue if you
wanted to play it safe you could use one
your shotgun shells smoke them I'm just
mad I like don't there both to your left
though how do you know last time I
thought one was to my right no think so
just go and then back up and you may
have backup cuz they're gonna hit me if
I have any other shotgun the sunshield
or go
turn around sprint back here oh wait
yeah go inch forward and see if you can
train yourself that might be good to
what to lure them go forward a little
bit and then back up back back up back
up back up back up back up a kill oh he
got me [ __ ] he got me
turn around you're fine you're fine
you're fine use one and then sprint down
the hallway No
yeah I've reset it sorry that's right
I've never been so upset about dogs did
you you did he'll know I'm on caution
well I got this I don't want them to
bum-rush you and then you get hit once
pause and then he'll should I go back to
my truck my gun right oh yeah I think
they're in this room got a time it right
so you don't let him get behind you
obviously I know that goes without
saying but like you reached they reset
they'd get behind me
but you dad but you didn't you weren't
ready to shoot them like they attacked
you before you Chewie you gotta be ready
to shoot can I just run past them you
want you can you could try running past
them and just getting into one of those
doors to your left dogs yeah I guess I
would recommend that try try to get into
one of the doors there's two how about I
take a left and then a right sure I'm
doing it just don't stop moving you're
low just keep keep running Trent eyes
dude that's unfortunately running to the
one at the end the hallway I'm not gonna
make it oh is that one locked you I
don't know you're good [ __ ] I hope not
oh [ __ ] okay he'll this is the worst
yeah
combined mmm yeah I'm in danger I know
but just use one it'll this [ __ ] it'll
only bring it back it's only get ready
up back up the caution anyway that's
like I say use one okay no you're good
sweet okay you're at the top of danger
okay just [ __ ] kill them now I'm so
sick of these dogs I don't I honestly
don't even know what the door the other
hallway is I think it's unlocked but I
don't want to like make me run to it and
get hurt a lot
I the problem is I have all these
goddamn shotgun shells but if they're
not in front of me if they jump behind
me they're all so funny right now I
think just at least shoot ones they
don't bomb rush you
oh you're totally boom do it oh okay do
it out white good do it again
talkative both of them okay that was
worth it oh I felt so good sorry okay
I'm upset there's that greener back up a
hallway but he's so dejected
should I go through here if it's
unlocked
check that okay
I'm afraid I don't remember what's
through here I hate dogs
nope I hear them okay okay okay so get
out of here
there's a red plant I know but you don't
have there's a greener back at the
beginning that hallway yep combine them
first of all put your shopping away I
would say she's you're hanging on now
because it's one hallway we know what
happens with me and dogs though
I was like keep going forward if you can
really get the camera to shift and then
just be ready to shoot ready to shoot
hold on a second I wouldn't go out here
yet go back and try the other doors in
the hallway just explore that a little
bit more suck it you got a red arrow
there's a green arrows beginning the
hallway that's right but I need to
combine them before I put myself in
danger no don't worry about getting it
yeah just so glad I killed those dogs
yeah me too all right try these doors
that's gonna be like I think yeah it
looks like a locked door oh my god
if it's dogs I'm gonna be really mad I
hate dogs the corner
okay combined
that scared the [ __ ] out of me I was
like [ __ ] is that a red herb - that
won't help
like when I mean it's really clearly a
trainer meant like when you I told you
explore a little more I thought I
remembered summer
the hell am I
yeah okay
I mean I move any of these switches hold
on
this is like a puzzle you want to screw
up okay seconds back up for now yeah cuz
uh
I can't I guess up just dude to back out
you should be look back out okay wait
serious up 36 wait up
what it won't let me
it will let me go hang on
yeah just go down sure they go back down
- okay wait Helen I think we think is
through 36 will bring you to your 22
right now
I'll bring the 58 go up so later at 58
down down
wait no hold on yeah down wait what do
you right now 40:58 44 then up you don't
want to hit 80 so yeah yeah sorry wait
wait if you hit 80 you want a Haiti
right um go down because I'm pretty I'm
trying over like 80 will blow you up or
not yeah okay I think you want to haiti
and then knock on the red
rady 80 was in the red that's something
yeah take that yeah then check that
should show you some
oh okay I'm still in the red though here
okay so leave it on the room next to you
okay what is that like a good room is
this power supply weightlifting room is
where they go to
so I need to put the power on for that
one and then there's this one I don't
know if I got there happen well why do
you not speak faster because I'm letting
yeah I'm not I don't want just like [ __ ]
up sometimes oh god not now times I
don't hear anything
doesn't that scare you no zombies scare
me did I do that
No do you know who that says not yet
from Rosie Oh for
it's not Jill or Claire ate a long
a double oh I know her from later one
what are you doing
yeah she's got the bunch a turn four and
six he's one of those reporter types
I heard he was locked up in the
cellblock only there's a wrecked car
barring the entrance I've been trying to
find another way inside
ada come on
not even the AI can control to make
controls
Tainos yeah we're really strong
eat a Wang
talk to our quick I can't
am I supposed to baby there's got the
door try go thither just be like wait
so just warp in here you don't wait hey
see you sucka okay so take our rizal
through the store just try both doors
okay here we go
nope I hear dogs turn around turn up
like a mushroom you probably be fine but
you might not want to risk it right now
should I try again try the other door we
don't know what's in there I just know
dogs are in the oh no I'm saying oh
there looks like there could be stuff on
here yeah that's where the dude is been
this is going okay what do you think
yeah there are people in here Oh sick
wait yes three what do you think take I
mean like the best thing to do would
take one at least but then check out the
rest of cuz the other ones blue I feel
like in situations like this I would
take so many plants like I find it
really strange that he's like sorry I'm
like super out of pockets oh what's that
let me guess you must be Ben right get
up now what do you want I'm trying to
sleep here is this the guy Ben you told
the city officials that you knew
something about what's been going on
didn't you what did you tell them and
who the heck are you I'm trying to find
my boyfriend his name's John he was
working for a branch office of umbrella
base remember the password username in
the first game it was John Naida yes
he's here in the city I don't know
anything and even if I did why would I
want to tell you okay I say we leave him
in there does anyone know where they put
the key to this cell I have it right
here officer what but I'm not about to
leave this cell those zombies aren't the
only things crawling around out there
you can't live in there
let's let me in let me in William get
out of here before you lead it right to
me
hey I'm not going anywhere I'm the only
cop left alive in this building
what look if you want to live then
you're gonna have to leave with me might
be a good place to end the episode
actually okay but do you even know how
to get out of the city there's a kennel
in the back of the building I can't
decide the kennel is a manhole go
through and it'll lead you to the sewer
entrance but it won't be easy all right
I'm done helping us just open it yeah I
thought he hated us she ditched me again
that's the kennel that's why you don't
want to go in there yet and I would
advise against that right a manhole
opener yeah that seems reasonable all
right I don't
okay I tried talking this [ __ ] again
no there's a kennel in the back of the
building the inside the kennel is a
manhole cool I wouldn't get through a
save room okay be easy
we'll save again yeah we can get to save
room next episode I'd say no we can go
do it now open your rap again because
there's it's always hard to remember
which ones are the closest feeling we
haven't seen one in a while know what's
in that oh that's just a button right
let me rap again so kennels to the left
there's another manhole to that other
area Oh can I take either manhole yeah
thinking straight we might wanna end the
episode here but I gotta save could save
like next episode all right I'll leave
that stuff running or whatever on the
next wait no you actually probably need
to save right it's not a ps4 you can't
just suspend it episode I can't pee I
can't suspend it okay I can go safe
she's got a long way I guess - how far
do you think I am through this game
about halfway really steam shorter then
remaster yeah resident then then remake
it's about the same like a really long
time yeah but that was also the remake
the remastered remake which they added
like the whole there's a lot of sections
that you play that weren't even in the
original is it no yeah I just I would
wait for these two doors I would go back
up and save and grab that other herb on
the way up and just stock up on [ __ ] get
back
probably a faster way than the way I'm
thinking right now but I just want to
you have a lot of good supplies or now I
get you back I really don't want to die
you got the manhole opener just okay
yeah come back this way I get the green
herb on the way here's the dodge some
dudes but you'll be fine should I take
this yeah this will be my last item
yum yum yum yum yum yum yummy okay so is
there any dudes only under those I like
to mentally prepare myself they're going
to be I mean you're in that little
hallway off of precinct I hate this what
did i do last time
yeah come come here come get some of
these buns
open your mouth quick
oh there's a hallway there's another
door in that hallway and it goes down
faster no that goes upstairs why do I
think it that'd be faster to a saver if
I would go that way I try that way um I
try it yeah just add your arm and then
you might have think of it just to see
you don't oh no wait this way yeah that
way oh this will bring you back up no
this will bring you back up outside
yeah yeah okay this is saving right
appear perfect and you're also close to
everything else this is back where we
started
oh well no it's full circle I know but
still that noise is reasonable all right
nice it was not the dots made it
entertaining but you're actually you're
good you're in good shape so many deaths
sitting here dun dun dun dun
scram bomb that's when you know okay not
so shabby or too shabby a little shabby
keep everything else yeah okay I got
four ink ribbons left that's not a lot
but according to Mike well okay there we
are saying about halfway
you're good you're fine okay saved thank
you guys for watching we will be trying
to go back to doing two a week instead
of one that was just because we were
traveling but we should be back back in
the action so check back again for
another episode of Resident Knievel